michelle k fragt würdest du gerne mit
lous budget und links in einer wg wohnt
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir machen heute mal
eine kuh endrunde das gibt es braucht
man ja eigentlich relativ selten zu
sehen aber heute machen wir das einfach
mal denn es ist zeit dafür ganz einfach
es einfach zeit
ich habe euch gebeten unter dem hashtag
fragen sei das auf twitter fragen zu
stellen
das amt gemacht angehören werde bei euch
und wir legen direkt mal los die erste
frage kommt von hac red zac um ihr heißt
fragen sie das hattest du mal eine
zahnspange noch schnell lob aussprechen
deine videos sind super mach weiter so
ok danke schön an dich sache heißt er
glaube ich ich hatte keine zahnspange
davon blieb ich verschont ehrlich gesagt
nicht so gut zahnspange das gab es bei
mir nie comeback frage also atomic als
der kollege warum fragen sie nach fragen
anstatt sich selber welche zu überlegen
tomic
einfach auch wenn nötig zu sein
dankeschön kein spaß kein spaß ist immer
spaß
ich mache keinen spaß der thommy gerade
wieder eine fünf minuten konstant gut
die expertin fragt at&s gezockt was hast
du in den ferien vor
also ich hab ja eigentlich schon vor
einiger zeit ich mache eine fortbildung
im boden also html css javascript in den
ganzen case den lerne ich jetzt von der
pike auf das finde ich mega spannend
machen richtig bock ansonsten werde ich
noch eine reise machen aber dazu fragt
später noch mal wenn dazu noch eine
frage kommen vielleicht kommt dann noch
eine
ich weiß es nicht und ansonsten
natürlich auch urlaub und gamescom
selbstverständlich und dann geht's im
september bei mir wieder weiter aber bis
dahin habe ich ja ich habe auch so schon
in vollen stundenplan sich stream ja ich
mache videos macht die fortbildung sport
noch nebenbei das ist auch schon ne
menge okay gut das gerade überhaupt
nicht mit ab fragt was ist deine
lieblings airline
ich weiß was meine lieblings ändern ich
weiß es nicht man kann es glaube ich
nicht sagen als wir meinen namen
aussprechen
welches die lieblings airline ist denn
die airlines ergeben sich immer aus der
situation
die vergleiche und welcher leyen grad
kohlers klar ich habe schon richtig gute
airline vergleiche fluglinien
vergleichen kann ich mich gerade an
einen erinnern
ich glaube nicht wenn ich ganz nebenbei
hier noch jobs spiel dann ist man
relativ afk away from rufen kann das
gehirn away sein way from power lp
vodafone dem afd nächste frage el
calafate wer ist dein waro drei
teampartner ja leute das wohlig in
letzter zeit schon öfter gefragt
ich habe mich aber noch entschieden doch
entschieden dass noch nicht öffentlich
zu machen
ihr müsst ihr noch ein bisschen gedulden
meint partner wird noch nicht
bekanntgegeben gegeben er steht aber
schon fest
und ich kann nicht sagen dass es ein
sehr sehr sehr attraktiver und unfassbar
kompetenter zeitgenosse ist den ich auch
so sehr mag ihr aber man weiß noch nicht
wer es ist
aber danke für die frage einfach nur
marie fragt was macht ihr mehr spaß
streamen oder youtube videos drehen
also ich finde streamen gerade wenn sich
so lange zeit ehrlich gesagt schon schon
anstrengend das ist persönlich finde ich
jetzt wirklich anstrengend allerdings
macht sich viel mehr aber auch mehr spaß
oder stream hat an sich relativ viel
spaß weil man direkt mal sein man kann
seine eigene musik hören man kriegt
irgendwie man kann ein bisschen mit den
leuten chatten
man kriegt ihr feedback das finde ich
cool aber es ist wie gesagt deutlich
anstrengender also der spaß ich hab gar
nicht so viel spaß am videos drehen ich
habe eigentlich mehr spaß daran videos
zu schneiden muss ich sagen wobei die
dass ich keinen spaß und trainer das
kann auch nicht sagen aber es macht mir
mehr spaß videos zu schneiden
aber an sich würde ich sagen dass switch
mehr spaß macht aber anstrengender ist
okay wir haben das jetzt hier springen
so das feld so spahn okay es geht
irgendwie so gerade gar nicht habe ich
vielleicht ein bett übersehen was
dazwischen drin ist bleibt vielleicht so
geht auch okay als zack und dann können
wir euch direkt die nächste folge hall
machen würdest du luder dort heiraten
fragte miss kranich also lud würde ich
selbstverständlich nicht heiraten wie
kann man so etwas fragen junger danke
und noch hier
dankeschön lud werde ich natürlich nicht
heiraten aber die hardware
ich würde nicht irgendwie heiraten so
sehr vielleicht würde ich ihn heiraten
oder nicht ist lassen wir an dieser
stelle mal offen alter wie unnötig der
jump bus an der stelle ist wegen jumps
habe ich bin ich jetzt gerade nicht in
diese lücke da reingekommen dankeschön
dankeschön play meine lag meine tiere
blumen alter okay dann xdc ly verhakt
wie sehr hast du blut so sehr ich kann
es nicht beschreiben wenn ich dran denke
dann durch ein anfang wenn ich den sehe
dann mache ich erstmal richtig fertig
dann bis ich dann erstmal ohne witz ich
mache ich das nicht möchten sie wir
müssen immer muss es machen
als gäbe es eine verpflichtung mich zu
zeugen dankeschön ja okay frage numero
nächste frage keine ahnung die gefühlte
nummer das ist
lp mit party fragt bist du real
darauf kann ich auch entgegnen dass ich
diese frage persönlichen nicht
beantworten kann
wobei eigentlich ist das ist es gar
keine so einfache frage hängt von der
von der eigenen theologischen
weltanschauung ab hängt davon ab wie der
eigenen meinung nach die welt entsteht
ich würde sagen ich bin eher konstruktiv
ist oder oder so lips ist es okay gut
wie ich bin bin ich realistisch sagen
ich habe keine ahnung vielleicht
schreibt ihr mal in die kommentare ob
ihr realzeit ich würde mich persönlich
er mit ihr identifizieren kann es
verstehen ja ok neuer bayern nico fragt
was erhoffst du dir von dem treffen mit
den gewinnern von 50k special
wenn du dir überhaupt etwas heraus also
was ist dir hoffe ich meine das ist
eigentlich ein dankeschön an euch also
hier nicht so dass ich da das dass ich
das für mich mache und ich mache das für
euch erstmal okay da kann man auch auf
jeden fall mal nicht lang da muss man
glaube ich raus muss man hier raus
minimum bisschen rausnehmen erklärte ich
erhoffe mir einfach dass die leute zeit
haben die da sind das ist sind meine
erwartungen daran ansonsten wie gesagt
geht es eher darum dass ich euch was
zurückgeben
das ist für mich mache genau pixel kind
14 fragt wie findest du fan pages für
dich und gibt es welche auf die duos
aufmerksamkeit also definitiv es kay
news das eine sehr sehr präsente
facebook fanpage oder den newspaper das
ja im prinzip relativ ähnlich dies halt
ja wirklich überall dabei
in streams immer auf twitter jederzeit
übrigens falls ist in der facetime seht
ja ich habe mich tatsächlich geschnitten
als ich hab da so ein bisschen blatt im
face steht alter schon wieder darüber
gesprochen nicht mein ernst warum ich
diese andere kreatur schon wieder dabei
der waschen der setzen ohne dabei hat
befindet der ich mich auf mann geweckt
junge
ich will finnischen als ob zehn sekunden
noch was oder und müssen dingen nein
kann nicht öffentlich auf den scheiß
okay gut dann das dev teams man hier
über so kampling ist vielleicht nicht so
der optimale modus unfalls verantworten
hat die absolut recht aber ja so sehr
schöner star jude law order verein
überhaupt nicht benutzt das schon fast
antik kuss verliebt fragt was hast du
heute schon gemacht
ich bin aufgestanden habe alles
gefrühstückt relativ nice ihr typisches
frühstück für mich als ich es gerne mal
ein bisschen ungewöhnlicher nehmen ich
habe aber tatsächlich gehauen
zwei herzen
okay er hat mich nie wieder es war nicht
mein kind von dem ghanaer ist ok er
markiert den freshen spawn kiel bei dem
man dann setzt er jetzt kriegt er jetzt
kriegt er ab wo alles was schön
wunderbar ich habe heute morgen
gefrühstückt was wahrscheinlich relativ
komisch klingen wird eine mischung aus
zwar ein spätzle von gestern gestern ich
mit spätzle gemacht mit hartz iv sahne
soße dazu nutzt schokolade und
wassermelone
das klingt wie wunderbar verrückt
erklärt aber ich klatschen sozialen
junge komm komm ich her der dessen
vertreter bis gesehen er stand einfach
sogar dafür zwei sekunden macht nichts
welches der habe ich schon gesagt
welches team in waren konkurrenz sein
wird ich habe tatsächlich für diese juni
mehrere aufnahmen versuche aber ich
würde sagen größte konkurrenz habe ich
schon glaube ich gesagt falls ich nicht
gesagt habe ich sage es noch mal wen und
und wählen wen und wählen und sein
teampartner würde ich sagen
bitte nicht so wie man werde nicht die
wollen danke schön danke ich weiß es
sehr zu schätzen
gold auf dem bogen
der bogen aber der talentierte junge
junge junge klappt ich hab nur noch ein
leben das war jetzt ein bisschen riskant
konnten uns nicht rausnehmen
darum kommt er sicher noch was die 05 11
fragt bist du morgen in köln
nein ich bin gern in meiner bude und
morgen nicht in köln
da musste ich leider enttäuschen leid
aber wir die fluglinie mit ganz ganz
wenig beinfreiheit
so nochmal combo nicht mehr leben junger
jetzt hab ich mich gut rüstung sehr
schön perfekt das war richtig wichtig
das war echt wichtig sei nicht nicht
gekommen dass die herner uns von hinten
weg klappdach komme ich immer vor den
feiern teil
wie findest du die map von ziegler
schwange leute im als politiker kann ich
gar nicht ich kann gar keine politik
läuft muss ich sagen so sagt du bist
mich haben du bist michael ich das wird
nun nicht funktionieren wenn jetzt
weiter hinten rum und dann abstaubt und
natürlich nicht nehmen in der junge ein
herz und ein fahrzeug sehr nice das war
sehr gut das risiko hat sich gelohnt
das meine ich mit aggressiven spielweise
das ist bei sowas reingehe
ja okay was in ein weg von der kiste
steht
ja verpiss dich gleich okay der nach dem
nach dem noch wissen 04 trading okay
natürlich türlich türlich ich will mal
die page und kokos darum ist da drin ist
die amazon freundlich ausgeht was neuen
jungen ein junger was was warum jetzt
die vier gedrückt mein volk kam nicht
okay brennt ein herz einfach kein herz
ok
okay okay okay vielleicht noch einen
fall geben dürfte dauern sein
ein feiern feiern feiern und vor allem
vorsichtig sein
vor junge wie knapp diese runde ist
älter ich werde auch gegen wales wo
junge
er brennt turner verbrennt das ist gut
okay da hatte auf zwei leben jetzt
kommen noch eine letzte frage auswahl
alter was was für ein deathmatch war das
wiegt knapp 34 situation richtig richtig
knapp war ganz oben nochmal amish lka
fragt würdest du gerne mit lous j und
liegt in einer wg wohnen mit lous j j
und legt ja ganz ehrlich ich würde ich
finde sowas ecole seine youtube wickie
ist eigentlich echt nice ich hatte die
boots vielleicht machen ziehen
ich mag das deswegen würde ich sagen ja
jetzt nichts mehr hören ich mag einfach
nicht dass nicht nur noch bernd locker
es geht aber dann und und und und und
okay die wunderbar haben wir noch eine
letzte frage raushauen
wenn du entscheiden müsste ist was du
statt youtube tun solltest was wäre das
statt youtube und co